[Musique]
6h50 pourquoi
et le bateau pour aller au collège
parce que c'est beau ou pas ouais c'est
beau
j'en ai là c'est bien c'est beau et tout
mais l'hiver c'est pas la même chose on
arrive
il fait très beau
à toute
je me suis endormie tout à l'heure en
cours
ils savent pas faire du vélo quand nous
on fait du vélo l'été on se fait
engueuler parce que on fait pas bien du
vélo il y a pas de petit train le petit
train qui fait le ramassage scolaire
quand il y a des touristes et bah il
fait le tour de l'île avec les touristes
et donc du coup bah il nous prend pas
il y a pas de bonne chance
il y a une voiture c'est la voiture de
la planète
[Musique]
vivre ici
genre d'aller voir ailleurs d'aller voir
des gens de rencontrer plein de gens je
veux pas partir pour toujours ça c'est
sûr je vais forcément revenir un moment
de toute façon j'ai de la famille j'ai
mon père j'ai mes parents qui sont là
je pourrais jamais partir pour toujours
tu te balades comme si c'était chez toi
partout là je me balade quoi
ça a été à la chapelle-saint-michel non
j'adore la musique et tout ce qui est
festival tout ce qui est théâtre et tout
j'adore et du coup j'avais vraiment
travaillé dans l'événementiel mais c'est
encore un projet pas très concret pour
aller à des concerts je suis obligé
d'aller loin les gros artistes ne
viennent pas près de chez vraiment à
Rennes à Nantes et vraiment c'est loin
Nantes enfin c'est à 4h d'ici quoi
tu es trop
vous avez vu un ascenseur
on a eu une superbe éducation vu qu'on
était pas beaucoup à l'école on était 4
mais après c'était des une grande classe
avec plusieurs niveaux le soir parfois
on sort on n'a pas forcément d'heure
pour rentrer chez nous et nos parents
ils se demandent pas vraiment ce qu'on
fait où on va se connaissent tout le
monde ils connaissent l'environnement
[Musique]
pas avoir peur ça n'a pas grand chose
qui pourrait vous arriver ici quoi
il y a plein de gens on peut sortir on
va se baigner il fait beau l'été c'est
un truc de fou divers c'est nul nul nul
nul mercredi
mais pas du tout alors ouais ça faudrait
arrêter
ça c'est déjà arrivé oui ça m'est déjà
tu vois et toi c'est quoi le truc le
plus débile qu'on t'a demandé si j'avais
des toilettes parfois il y a des gens
qui me font des réflexions ah tu savais
pas ça bah non bah forcément tu habites
dans une grotte mais non j'habite pas
dans une grotte enfin je sais pas
forcément on habite sur une île c'est
différent je crois que ça nous rend pas
trop différent genre ça te va bien